so here's why he should be your
boyfriend in a month
and now i don't mean that
you guys are still in the talking stage
and you're in the talking stage for a
month and all of a sudden he's going to
be your boyfriend
but to that point you should also not be
in a talking stage for longer than a
week two at most pause that [ __ ] yeah
okay that [ __ ] um here is why she she
should [ __ ] with you within three days
or dumb that [ __ ] okay
same thing
same same
don't don't don't put a threshold on the
and we don't we're not allowed to do it
don't do it
all right [ __ ] all this [ __ ] it's the
same energy this is why if she doesn't
shut the [ __ ] up with your [ __ ] okay
and i know that not everyone meets
online so some things do take time to
develop if you meet in person through
mutual friends or a setup or
through work but from the time that you
go out on a first date
that is where the countdown begins from
the time that you went out on a date
with him and you guys kissed he should
be your boyfriend in a month well how
about i want to take my time
why yo what words for one person doesn't
necessarily work for another person you
know people ask me for advice i cannot
give you advice on your relationship
what's your secret [ __ ] ain't no secret
partially i got lucky and whatever i
winged it and if i get to another
relationship knock on wood whatever if i
get into another relationship you think
i'm gonna do the same thing i'm gonna
they want no because they're not the
same person i'm gonna wing it
the reason why a lot of women get strung
along by men
for longer than a month three months six
months with no relationship title
is because you don't require much from
him now let me tell you something when
you require more from men you end up in
a relationship and not only that but
you've proven to him that you have
standards and if they don't meet your
standards then you walk away you end up
alone you end up alone
most girls i know are
standards to understand they end up
alone but a lot of people that have that
that when you say i got a lot of sailors
they're not having a lot of standards
you're being difficult with a bunch of
[ __ ] well they really end up in a
relation no they end up alone they're
gonna they end up lonely
i'm not gonna lie any girl gives me an
ultimatum or a timeline or a countdown
i'm walking away after one month how
many dates have you been on what kind of
relationship time do you guys have are
you seeing each other every day every
other day once a week
how often are you talking
one month between certain couples can
feel like a year for other people it
could feel like
one week that means because they always
it varies from person to person so
that's why if you're watching this at
home when you're listening to these
rules maybe there's some truth behind
some of the ideas behind it and that
like yay you probably shouldn't be
sleeping with somebody for six months
wanting a relationship and they're not
giving you any reciprocity that seems
like a long timeline but maybe that
makes sense for you because there's
something to be said about maybe what do
you do
there's something to be said about
living in a gray area
you want something the other person's
not there yeah okay but you also have to
understand it's a give and take you
can't be so rigid about what you want
without understanding where the other
person's coming from because if you want
that individual you have to take their
wants and their desires into
consideration and be flexible you get
what i'm saying like no no it's all
about what i want
this is my standard you don't meet my
standard then you out
whoa chill you know you do know that
there's two [ __ ] in the
relationship right well in the normal
relationship
some people can be in relationships with
themselves sure i married me
have a sensible conversation i think
it's fine to broach a topic like hey
where do you see this going are we going
to be moving this along or is this going
to be something you want to just kind of
stay casual with what are you feeling
have a conversation don't say the
ironclad rule
and then motherfucker's going to be
bitter uh
i had my one month threshold and then he
went with that other [ __ ] and then they
did three three weeks and it was fine
because it was a different [ __ ]
yeah some people so she required that
from him or maybe he just enjoyed the
vibe with her a lot more than he did
with you
that happens
see men actually get into relationships
with women who require more of them than
women who just are doormats that will
accept
mixed signals except busted behavior
except them being strung along with no
title and i know those women are gonna
say well i'm just patient i'm just
giving him grace i'm gonna give him the
benefit of the doubt i don't wanna rush
things what you're actually doing is
relaying to him that you're perfectly
okay with giving him sex and
doing things for him without requiring
him to be your boyfriend you know what
kills me about this
is
you can be dating somebody right and
maybe i don't rush into a relationship
with y'all taking your time with it and
she says
well if you're doing that basically
you're giving him sex and you're giving
him things it's like don't you think
it's reciprocal
but do women not enjoy sex anymore is
that not a thing is that no
are we not giving you sex no okay are we
not also doing other things we're not
going on dates we're not enjoying our
time together getting to know each other
starting to actually care and build upon
with the other person is that not
happening no we just [ __ ] is that
always what it is
needs is out here always [ __ ] they're
not getting closer to you at all because
there's no title there's no bond being
created right it took me nothing but 15
seconds to snap
but i'm just i'm just dying because i'm
like do they think we just walked
through life like that like we just out
here were we taking folks out on dates
and putting in time and putting in
effort like it's one thing if y'all just
doing the friends with benefits i've
come to my place we banging come to your
place we banged that's different y'all
going out and doing stuff and spending
time to get to know each other and all
this other stuff and maybe you meet
their friends or whatever like
clearly there's something else that's
building there even if it hasn't gone to
the point of being a relationship where
you guys are saying you're making that
next level commitment but anyways
the truth is you shouldn't even be
sleeping with him if he's not your
boyfriend um or it's not even going
there at all
hey you know what
i'm i'm gonna be generous today i'm
gonna be generous i'm gonna say this
maybe that's true for you maybe you're
somebody who outside of a relationship
any kind of
intimacy in that regards makes you feel
cheaper than lesson that's on you to fix
it's not something wrong with everybody
else it's not something wrong with other
women that's something that you're not
capable of and that's okay but this
whole thing like withholding sex
in order into a relationship well then
what if dudes were withholding
relationships until they get sex does
that seem fair does that seem acceptable
then you're never going to meet
because you should never parallel
it's actually your [ __ ] is parallel it's
never going to meet bruh you when you
require you inspire
i just noticed the caption
i just noticed the caption
when you require you inspire inspire
good way to weed out guys that aren't
serious is by having these requirements
so they meet your standards they call
you every day they're consistent and
when they drop the ball you fire them it
takes a lot nowadays for women to fire
guys when a long time ago
if a guy just stopped calling
you were out and she's moved on nowadays
women are waiting on a guy and that's
just so wrong and that's not how it's
supposed to be what's your standards
you're firing everybody
at some point if you fire everybody
you're not going to have someone
in your company see what i did there
company
fired
bars yeah i'm claiming bars she's
talking about back in the day if
somebody didn't call you back you just
moved on what are you talking about
like she did the same thing with the
other video where she's like oh man and
i've heard the countries they're so much
more forward and all this other stuff
targets
lady do you honestly think that people
back in the day just had like an
abundance of option and when someone
didn't call them back they moved on no
really they were obsessed
they're obsessed because they just got a
bit of attention from the only person in
town that's looked at them okay and
they're like [ __ ] i love you too right
that's what used to happen wonder why
because they didn't have online dating
they didn't have an abundance of options
they only knew the people around them so
it's like to me he's like what what
reality does he live in
people always do this thing the modern
day of aging of dating is so terrible
modern dating is the worst so what what
do you think past dating was like like
oh no
that one was way better right what was
it like she said some dumb [ __ ] like
that
oh yeah it's that same dating generation
that gave you 50 divorce rates that's
the one that you want to emulate the one
that couldn't maintain families and gave
us a whole bunch of kids from broken
homes that's the one that you wanna okay
go ahead girl
he's supposed to be waiting on you to
decide if he's worthy enough to be your
boyfriend not whether you're good enough
for him to decide that you're gonna be
his girlfriend what the [ __ ] did she
just say he's supposed to be waiting on
you to decide if he's worthy enough to
be your boyfriend not whether you're
good enough for him to decide that
you're gonna be his girlfriend so if she
if you get to decide
and
you haven't decided within a month
it's on you b listen this this actually
was so stupid
that it made everybody watching this
video
dumber but you know what
i'm not even gonna have that kind of
reaction because i'll tell you why
she's a dating coach
she sells courses just like derrick
jackson just like fresh and fit just
like a bunch of people in these spaces
their job is to tell their crowd that
you're the prize
why because if they tell you you're the
prize then they can embolden you and
then feed you into their loop of like
well this is why you're right and this
is why the other sex is wrong and why
they're doing things incorrectly it's
just that so she gotta say this [ __ ] for
you to give her money you don't have to
prove to him that you're a good
girlfriend he has to prove to you that
he's a good boyfriend what are you
[ __ ] talking about what does that
even mean
what do you think guys are just out here
like please pick me please is that
really how you think the society should
function this is why i'm going to be so
good to you is that really how you think
it should be i don't have to see any
qualities in you that make you a good
partner no
but it doesn't make any sense and i
think you as a viewer can probably tell
that as well so if we're watching this
then we have to ask yourself why is she
saying this dumb stuff is it because
she's just
brain dead
or
is it just a hustle is she is it is it a
hustle is she brain dead is she bitter
it could be a lot of things
yes but when you have a financial
incentive to say a lot of this stuff i'm
much more likely to think you're being
the fairest the same way i don't think
jared jackson's an idiot no i think he's
a good businessman yeah
he sold what he needed to the black
women yeah they ate that [ __ ] up yeah
found out he's a [ __ ] fraud like we
[ __ ] knew since the trump yeah this is
the female derek jackson
you're the prize ladies he has to prove
to you it's the same [ __ ] same thing
same mo so i didn't want to see this
stuff was like man why are we even
dissecting this this is dumb
this is more of that like you're the
prize ladies no you're the prize fellas
these women are [ __ ] these women like
these men can't keep a job they don't
got no money
same [ __ ] same [ __ ]
remember i told you guys like you flip a
coin
you start to realize out loud there's
like red pill feminist stuff is just two
sides of the same coin no they're
they're not they're on the same side
they're on the same side thinking
they're thinking the same way they're
not at the opposite
they're on the same side
they think the same way their mo
is the same they just that got different
views someone that is an extreme on the
right and wants to kill people and
someone on the left that's on the on the
extreme left and wants to kill people
they the same people they really are the
same people they just have different
subjects in which they want to kill
but the ammo is the same they're so
extreme they want to do the same thing
with that they're not different the
extreme midgal or the extreme whatever
that hates
women and talia used this and that and
whatever and extreme on the other side
they're the same people yeah and don't
worry in the comments there's gonna be a
bunch of people who were like no the
rapper is not like that and then there's
a bunch of women like no that's it
and you guys are the same people too but
i digress that's what i thought when i
watched this video i created super hard
and so let us know what you guys think
in the comments below